in this video what I want to talk about
is amino acids and really just a general
overview and brief introduction to amino
acids or what they are or why they're
important and what to look forward to
when we go over all sorts of different
things about them initially like I
mentioned I just want to introduce you
to them so what is an amino acid an
amino acid is essentially a compound
that has both an amino group compound
with both an amino group and a
carboxylic acid group so an amino acid
has an amino group and an acid group
nothing too crazy about that now what
why are they important they're important
because they're monomers right for
proteins they're monomers are basically
the the basic building block for
proteins right and proteins we know are
very very just important in biology and
it's it's important understand that
they're structures so amino acids that
we'll be talking about in future videos
are going to be alpha amino acids so
what is an alpha amino acid an alpha
amino acid is basically telling you that
the amino group is specifically on the
Alpha carbon okay and that will make
more sense once I actually draw it for
you so this means that the amino group
is on or connected to
the alpha carbon I get I'll explain that
in just a moment
okay now when I draw these amino acids
going to draw them what's called these
Witter ion form this winter ion ores
vitter ion form and this video I'll
inform is essentially just the form in
which it has no net charge again that
will make more sense once I've drawn it
out this is assuming at a pH of seven
right which is a neutral pH another
thing that we need to know about amino
acids that when we talk about them we're
going to be talking about specifically L
amino acids and the reason why is
because all the naturally occurring
proteins all the naturally occurring
amino acids that are in proteins will be
L amino acid and again I'll talk about
what that means
so all founded in L amino acids in
naturally occurring proteins okay so one
more thing I want to mention is that all
amino acids are chiral okay which is
what this L has to do with right all our
chiral except glycine okay okay which is
one of the amino acids one of the twenty
amino acids which is my last point here
so there are 20 of them okay so these
are some important points to keep in
mind one thing I wanted to do up here is
I want to abbreviate amino acid says
AAA's not Alcoholics Anonymous just
AAA's this because i don't want to keep
writing amino-acids every time I say
amino acids so maybe I'll be a little
bit easier to fall and I'll talk about
why glycine is an exception why it's not
chiral so it is not there's no such
thing as El glycine or D glycine
there's only glycine and I'll explain
then shortly so what does a general what
is the general structure of an amino
acid what does it look like so an amino
acid well we mentioned that it has an
amino group and a carboxylic acid group
right so this what I'm going to do is
I'm going to draw them in what's called
the Fischer projection ok so I'm going
to draw X let me draw it up here so I'm
going to draw the Fischer projection the
Fischer projection ok and I'm also going
to draw all these amino acids assuming
that the pH is 7 ok add it pH equal to 7
right which is why I mentioned this
holds good Ryeon form so an amino acid
would look like this ok so here this
intersection point here is a carbon up
here we're going to have a carboxylic
acid group now because it's an acidic
group right it will donate its proton so
instead of being pronated here it's
going to look like this going to have it
contain that negative charge over here
we're going to draw the amino group here
we have just an H and here we have an R
group I'll draw that in blue ok so that
is the R group now what are all these
different things so I want to label all
of these different things so this thing
up here right whoops where am I going
there we go this here is the alpha
carbon okay
why is it called the Alpha carbon well
if you remember back to organic
chemistry if you have a particular
carbonyl and a carbon right next to that
carbonyl will be considered an alpha
carbon so this
carboxylic acid group let me draw it
kind of right here is to kind of show
you what it would look like it would
look like this right so this is a
carbonyl and then it would be connected
to this carbon this carbon here is this
carbon here so this carbonyl right the
carbon that is connected to is this
carbon this carbon is considered the
Alpha carbon so this this carbon that's
the reason it's actually named that and
there are more details than that from
organic chemistry which I won't go over
in this video so this group here this
carboxylic acid group is considered the
Alpha carboxyl group okay this here is
the Alpha amino group right because in
amino Grubin is connected to the alpha
carbon okay
this H is just the hydrogen nothing
special about it it is going to indicate
a so you can call it the Alpha H but
it's not really of too much importance
when we're talking about the amino acids
this this R here represents some
sidechain okay now how many of these how
many different side chains are there
well there are twenty different amino
acid so there must be 20 different side
chains okay they're 20 different ones
now the way I've drawn this here I've
drawn it as an L amino acid okay so this
here is an L amino acid oh goodness
okay now the reason why is because in
these Fischer projections we sort any
any lines that are that are drawn like
this horizontal you you imagine them
protruding out towards you right and
then anything any vertical lines those
bonds are going into the plane away from
you okay so if you wanted to change this
L amino acid into a D amino acid well
all you would have to do is take two
substituents on that off of carbon and
switch them so what I normally do is if
I were to draw the drive I would just
I would just keep the carboxyl group and
the side chain in these same locations
and I would just switch the amino group
and the hydrogen oops I just thought I
would switch them and I wrote it again
sorry about that so here is going to be
the hydrogen and over here we'd have the
amino group so when we do that we change
the stereochemistry from L to D so this
would be ad amino acid but as I said all
naturally-occurring protocol proteins
have the naturally occurring elements in
them so we don't really sweat the DM you
know masses will pre usually don't draw
these out we don't really care about
them okay now where do the LNT sort of
come from they come from the basic idea
of of glyceraldehyde so I'm going to
draw glyceraldehyde in light blue
turquoise whatever you want to call it
now glyceraldehyde is a carbohydrate -
sugar it looks like this alright this is
it's Fischer projection now this one
here is d-glyceraldehyde this right if
this was if that's d-glyceraldehyde you
imagine what would happen quite simply I
would just switch the h in the yo H so
the H would be on the right side and the
O H would be on the left side so this
would be L glyceraldehyde okay so with
amino acids with amino acids um the L
form right the L form is what naturally
occurs in sugars the D form is naturally
occurring we'll talk about that later in
a future video okay that's just
something to kind of keep in mind for
now okay
but specifically amino acids L amino
acids are the ones that are naturally
occurring okay now I mentioned over here
that I've already talked about this why
what I mean a structure so hopefully
this makes sense right
compound that has an amino group and an
acid carboxylic acid group and this will
alpha carbon oh do that so that sort of
explains this alpha amino acid idea and
this would rely on form is the whole
idea that if it has no net charge then
the carboxylic acid right we'll add a pH
of 7 being an acidic group will donate
its proton the amino acid the amino
group being a basic will be protonated
I'll accept the proton again those those
definitions those the simple bronze that
definitions come into play almost all
the time I talked about this is all all
of them being found in L l
stereochemistry
all of them are chiral except glycine so
why why why haven't I talked about that
just yet so the reason why is because
glycine its side chain it's our group is
just a hydrogen ok so if I drew glycine
for you
glycine with it like this glycine would
have this carboxyl group here Cimino
group here so again this is assuming a
pH of 7 right it's our group is actually
just an H so what do you notice here now
in height in glycine what we find is
that these two substituents right are
both just hydrogen's right so in order
to be chiral in order to be chiral you
must have I just crossed at alpha but in
order to be chiral we have four
different substituents glycine does not
glycine does not have does not have four
different substituents okay because does
not because the R group is just an H
right so this little dash right next to
the R this is all - right next to the H
indicate a covalent bond right so this
is the covalent bond holding that alpha
carbon to that hydrogen so there are not
four different substituents
right which is a requirement for
chirality okay so hopefully that was a
good thorough brief introduction to
amino acids in future videos we'll be
talking about the actual structures of
the different amino acids how there are
there are some that are polar there some
that are nonpolar or some that are
acidic basic neutral I'll talk about a
little different things and kind of ways
to remember them but hopefully this
functions as a good introduction to
amino acids and how we'll be dealing
with them in biochemistry